ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
madame la ministre la corse a été le
premier territoire français à se doter
d'une pp en 2015 elle avait fait l'objet
d'un travail de convergence d'un vote à
l'assemblée de corse et d'un décret
ministériel 7 pp permettait
d'appréhender les prospective
énergétique de la corse en misant sur
une vraie politique d'efficacité
énergétique une meilleure intégration
des énergies renouvelables dans le mix
énergétique tout en prenant en compte la
vétusté de certains moyens de près de
production comme la centrale du vazzio
interconnexion entre la corse et
l'italie
aujourd'hui nous constatons que cette
paix pu unanimement saluée au niveau
national comme local mans qui avait
obtenu toutes les validations des
différentes commissions nationales et
qui avait réussi à obtenir l'accord de
la majorité des parties prenantes en
corse semble être remise en question
j'en veux pour preuve la lettre envoyée
à la collectivité de corse par nicolas
hulot alors ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire envoyé juste
avant sa démission ainsi que les
commentaires des uns et des autres dans
les médias
suite à la dernière rencontre que vous
avez eue avec l'exécutif régional
madame la ministre pourriez vous nous
faire savoir quelles sont les intentions
du gouvernement concernant la prochaine
pp en corse notamment regard des
éléments majeurs présents dans
l'actuelle ppe sachant qu'il y a urgence
et que les corses n'accepterons jamais
une prolongation des anciens moyens de
production qui doivent normalement être
déclassées en 2023 notamment l'actuel
central du vase qui est un outil
vieillissant sujet de nombreux incidents
et fonctionnant actuellement au fioul
lourd aller au delà de 2023 avec de tels
outils mettrait à l'évidence en risque
l'alimentation de la corse et
impliquerait de poursuivre un
fonctionnement fut lourd ce qui est
inacceptable pour la population du pays
ajaccien
plus précisément madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous dire si oui ou non le
gouvernement a l'intention de respecter
le décret du 10 décembre 2015 relatif à
la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie en corse qui prévoyait la
réalisation d'une infrastructure
d'alimentation en gaz naturel de la
corse la circulation avec un objectif de
mise en service au plus tard depuis 2000
23 ainsi que comme l'idée d'une
puissance de 250 mégawatts et la
converse
ont des moyens thermiques extrêmes plus
naturel je vous remercie
la parole est à madame jacqueline
gourault au ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur panunzi la corse fait l'objet
comme vous venez de le rappeler du fait
de son insularité d'une programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie à part et
d'une attention particulière du
gouvernement pour la sécurité de ses
approvisionnements énergétiques
aujourd'hui vous l'avez rappelé un tiers
de son électricité provient de centrales
thermique à fuel située à ajaccio et à
bastia qui sont vieillissantes et paul
menthe la ppe de 2015 a prévu que ces
installations seraient remplacées par
des centrales à gaz
à cet effet un projet consistait à
installer une barge de gaz à bastia et
de relier cette dernière par un gazoduc
traversant la corse jusqu'à ajaccio pour
alimenter la deuxième centrale
les difficultés sont sono cependant très
nombreuses comme vous le savez monsieur
le sénateur en particulier parce que le
trajet du gazoduc doit passer non
seulement au travers de la montagne mais
aux milliers de parcelles privées au
régime particulièrement complexe en
corse comme vous le savez nous avons
quand je dis nous c'est bien sûr le
ministre d'état ministre de l'écologie
et de la transition de la transition
écologique et solidaire pardon a reçu
très récemment et j'ai été présente à ce
rendez vous le président simeone et nous
avons exprimé à cet effet les doutes sur
la faisabilité de ce projet du gazoduc
et envisager de nouvelles pistes qui
pourraient passer par l'installation
d'un second terminal de gaz
potentiellement immergé en mer au large
d'ajaccio
le gouvernement est résolu à tenir ses
engagements dans la nouvelle ppe et bien
sûr veut s'assurer du renforcement de la
sécurité énergétique de la corse tout en
développant les énergies
et renouvelables